The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TADGE DRYJA: OK.
So today, I'll talk
about payment channels
and the lightning network.
And I am sorry if I
gloss over things.
I've explained this, like,
a lot in the last two years
because that's, sort
of, what I work on.
So I might skip over
something, and you're like,
wait, how did you get there?
So let me know.
So I'll have uni-directional
payment channels, and then
lightning channels.
And then, multi-hop.
OK, so the idea of
payment channels.
Why do we need to do all
this complicated, weird stuff
with payment channels?
Well, the problem
is these networks
are really poor in scalability.
Right?
Every transaction on the
blockchain, you know,
that whole idea doesn't scale.
People say it's O of n squared.
Depends on what you define as
n and then things like that.
So if you double the number
of nodes, it actually doesn't.
You can say, well, if you
double the number of nodes,
each node is going to be
making some transactions.
Right?
And then, you're
like, OK, yeah, it's
n squared if you count the
total number of computations
throughout the entire system.
But at the same time,
it's like, well, you've
doubled the number of nodes.
So really, it's O of n, right?
For any one computer,
your amount of computation
you have to do scales with how
many other computers there are.
So it's a little questionable.
But basically, it
doesn't scale well.
Right?
It doesn't scale
to what you want.
And so I put a little history
at the first response of anyone
ever referring to Bitcoin.
So there was a 2008--
like October, Halloween 2008,
or maybe after midnight, so
November 1st--
and Satoshi wrote,
I've been working
on a new electronic cash system
that's fully peer-to-peer,
with no trusted third party.
Then, he has a little blurb.
The first reply on this
mailing list was some guy--
James A. Donald--
saying, we very,
very much need such
a system, but the way
I understand your
proposal, it does not
seem to scale to
the required size.
So that was the
first thing anyone's
ever said about Bitcoin.
And we're still talking about
it almost 10 years later.
I wonder who James Donald is.
Maybe he's got a ton of
Bitcoin now and he mined it.
So it was written
about in late 2008.
The actual software
was released in 2009.
There was a couple emails.
No one really looked into
it much, at the time.
OK, so you can start with
a one way payment channel.
I think Satoshi, sort of,
mentioned these ideas.
Never really
implemented anything.
And the way he talked about
it didn't actually work.
Some people in 2012 I
remember looking at this.
I think [INAUDIBLE]
and Mike Hearn
gave a talk about how you
could make payment channels.
That didn't quite work either,
but the idea made sense.
So the idea is you have
some kind of shared
balance between two parties.
And you can move
coins in one direction
without making new
transactions on the blockchain.
So if you look at
a transaction--
you probably have seen this
kind of thing through homework--
it's got a lock time.
And in this case,
the lock time is 0.
That means this transaction
is valid at any point.
Above height 0, it's valid.
And every block
is above height 0.
You can also find
transactions, let's see,
which has a block time of this.
So this looks like a Unix
time where you set a time.
This is like a Unix time.
So Unix time, if
you don't know, it's
seconds since January 1, 1970.
That's, sort of, like
the first second.
And I don't know.
That's probably a
week ago or something.
So you can have that
field in a transaction.
The idea is the transaction
is only valid after that time
or height.
It's a little weird.
Below-- what is it--
500 million, it
counts as a height.
Above 500 million, it
counts as a Unix time,
which ends up working because
the Unix times below 500
million are in the 80s.
So you know, Bitcoin
didn't exist then.
There's no real need to
have time locks them.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: What about when you
get that far in block height?
TADGE DRYJA: About what?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Don't
you eventually get
that far in block
height, though?
TADGE DRYJA: 500 million?
Yeah, couple thousand years.
So yeah.
No, there's way more problems
with Bitcoin before that.
The time field in the
header is four bytes.
So if it was
signed, it'd be 2038
that it flips over
and goes negative.
But it's unsigned, so
you got until 2106.
There's actually a
hard fork to fix that.
So you know, there's
all sorts of weird,
like, wait, what do we do in the
hundreds of thousands of years?
We have to make these little
tweaks, which, hopefully,
wouldn't be super controversial
because it's like, well, it'll
stop working unless we
change this little thing.
OK.
So yeah, you can have
these lock times.
And you can use those.
So what you can do
is make a channel.
And a channel is really
just a multisig output.
Multisig, a lot of
times, is used for--
I don't want to say two
factor authentication--
but you could have
two of two multisig
where your phone needs to sign,
and your desktop needs to sign.
And then, if someone
steals your phone
or you know hacks your
phone and gets the key out,
well, they have to
also get your computer.
So this is useful.
But in these cases, it's,
sort of, adversarial multisig
where it's not just you and you.
It's not like your
phone and your computer.
OK, it's Alice and Bob.
They're completely
separate people.
They're not necessarily friends.
You know, it could be a
customer merchant kind of thing.
And they create a
transaction together.
So they fund it.
And Alice is funding
this channel.
And so she takes her own
coins, her own txid:index,
her own output, signs it,
and sends to an Alice and Bob
multisig and sends 10 coins.
So in order to spend this,
they both have to cooperate.
But before doing this, Bob
gives her a refund transaction.
So the idea is, if Alice just
broadcasts this and says,
OK, I'm taking my coins
and I'm sending it
to Alice and Bob multisig,
Bob can just disappear.
And then, Alice is stuck.
And the money's
stuck there forever
because Bob can never sign.
Or Bob can say, oh, Alice,
looks like you sent 10 coins.
How about this.
I'll give you nine of them.
You just give me one of them.
You're not buying anything.
This is just I'm holding
your coins hostage.
Bob could even make a even
better threat and say,
I will sign a bunch of
time lock transactions.
If you want your money
today, you only get one coin.
If you want your money in a
week, you'll get two coins.
And you know, sign these
things with lock times.
Hand all the transactions
over to Alice and say,
well, you can pick.
How long do you want to
wait to get your money back?
And then, Alice's only
response is, oh shoot, well,
if I wait years, maybe I'll
get most of my coins back.
But if I want my
money now-- you know,
there's all sorts of
horrible hostage situations,
even if they both
have money at stake.
One person could have
less time value of money.
So they're like, look, I
don't need this anytime soon.
So I'm willing to wait.
So this is dangerous.
So what they do
beforehand is Alice says,
hey Bob, give me a
refund transaction.
So Bob signs a
refund transaction
with a lock time of one
week from now, March 28.
And the input is the
fund transaction ID.
Even though the fund transaction
comes later, thanks to segwit,
you can say I know what
the Tx ID's gonna be.
I'm gonna reference
a spin for that.
And Bob's signature is
going to be on there.
Bob signs it.
Hands it over to Alice.
Alice's signature
is not there yet.
So Alice can sign it and
store it on her drive,
or she can sign later.
But until March 28th, this
transaction is not happening.
If you try to broadcast it,
everyone will reject it.
In the output from this
refund transaction,
it just sends to Alice's
address, all 10 coins.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do they
know the transaction
in the future, the
transaction ID in the future?
TADGE DRYJA: Oh, how do
they know the funds Tx ID?
Alice can calculate
it and tell Bob.
Alice can say I'm building
a fund transaction.
Alice knows her inputs.
She doesn't actually
have to sign it all
because the Tx ID won't
contain the signature
and what their key is.
So Alice can compute the Tx ID
and tell Bob, hey, sign this.
You know, this is
what the transaction
is going to look like.
Sign it.
And Bob, at this
point, has no risk.
Bob, I guess, needs to make
sure that he's not inadvertently
signing his own money.
So if Alice says,
hey, here's the Tx ID,
Bob should make sure,
OK, this is not my Tx ID.
Right?
But it actually doesn't matter
since he, sort of, commits
to Alice's pub key here.
So even if you've swapped
the Tx ID, when you sign,
you say this is two
of two multisig.
So if this was Bob's
single key, it wouldn't it
wouldn't even work.
Yeah, so Alice has to give
some information to Bob.
Bob signs, hands the
refund over to Alice,
then Alice is able to create
this fund transaction.
And now Alice's risk is
minimized because she says,
OK, I'll send this to this
channel and, worst case,
I have to wait a week.
Right?
If Bob disappears as
soon as I broadcast this,
well, then Bob's gone.
I can't do anything.
We can't sign.
But then, next week, I'll be
able to use this transaction
and get all my money back.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You said
that if this refund
transaction is broadcasted, all
the notes will be discarded.
TADGE DRYJA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But then--
TADGE DRYJA: This week.
AUDIENCE: --it has to
be sent before Alice
sends out the other
transaction, right?
Because what makes
sure that Alice
will have this transaction
up there in the systems
before the other transaction,
before they're bought?
TADGE DRYJA: Which transaction?
So there's the fund
and the refund.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
So the refund must be
sent before the fund.
TADGE DRYJA: No, it needs to
be created before the fund.
Right?
So it's not going to
be on the network.
But Bob creates this
first, signs it,
and gives it to Alice.
That way Alice knows,
well, I have this
that will be valid in a week.
And so that means it's safe
to sign and broadcast this.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And the
refund just requires
Alice's initial signature.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They're [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
So the refund transaction,
it's got Bob's signature.
And that's what
hand you hand over.
And then, Alice can sign later.
She can sign it immediately on
reception and then store it.
Or she can sign
it on March 28th.
But the idea is she's got
Bob's signature endorsing this.
And it's not valid yet, but
she knows minimize risk.
Right?
Worst case, wait a week.
OK, so then what can
you do with this?
You can make, sort of, similar
to refund transactions,
but they give Bob more money.
So you make two outputs.
You say, OK, I'm spending
the fund transaction ID.
I put Alice's signature.
And I say Alice gets nine coins.
Bob gets one coin.
And Alice hands
that over to Bob.
So you make a transaction
like that, right.
It spends the fund
transaction output.
Alice and Bob's key
are both needed.
And Alice signs this and
says, OK, I get nine.
You get one.
Hands it over to Bob.
And Bob says, basically,
I just got the money.
I can broadcast this if I want.
Right?
Bob's got Alice's signature.
Bob can add his signature.
Broadcast this transaction,
and receive one Bitcoin.
OK, but see, Bob doesn't
sign his side in broadcast.
Bob just waits.
Bob's like, cool,
I've got this coin.
I'm not even going to
sign and broadcast this.
I know it's as good
as having received
the actual coin because
there's nothing else Alice
can do on her own.
She can't take these 10 coins.
She can, eventually, get
the refund in a week.
But for now, Bob's safe.
And then, maybe a
day later Alice says,
OK, I'm giving you another coin.
What I'm doing is I'm
signing a new transaction.
It spends the same output.
This is still there.
These have not been broadcast.
But in this one, Alice
gets eight coins.
Bob gets two coins.
Alice signs it.
Hands that over to Bob.
Bob's like, great,
I got another coin.
I will also just wait.
Bob can actually delete this
because, well, this is better.
Right?
From Bob's perspective, I'd
rather have two than one.
And any of them are valid.
According to the network,
the network itself,
no one's seen these things.
They're not broadcast.
Only this exists as an output.
And you can keep doing this.
You can keep doing this
as many times as you want.
Well, within limits, right?
What's the obvious limit here?
AUDIENCE: 10 BTC
when Alice bought it.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
Sure.
Once Bob gets all 10, there's no
reason to keep it open anymore.
Also, you can't reverse.
Right?
So Alice is always
sending money.
If Bob says, hey, I'm going
to give you some money back,
and Bob signs something and
say, hey, now I have two coins
and you have eight coins.
Alice is like, yeah,
but you have this.
Right?
You have this Alice
7 Bob 3 transaction.
I know you can broadcast
that whenever you want.
So there's no
credible way for Bob
to say like, oh, I'm giving you
the money back in this channel.
Right?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: But what if the
next transaction Alice signs--
so she gave 1, 2, and 3.
And the next one, she gives
Bob 2.5 and keeps 7.5.
Is that right?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, Bob
would just ignore it.
Bob would be like, yeah,
but I already have three.
Why would I want 2 1/2?
And it's more
like, in that case,
if Alice says, oh,
I have two, Alice is
trying to take some money back.
Essentially, Bob is paying
Alice, in that case.
But it's not credible.
Alice is like, yeah,
I can sign this again.
Or I have all 10 again.
But you know, Bob's
idea is like, I'm just
going to sign the one
where I get the most money.
So you know, that's
a limitation.
It's one direction.
Alice can keep paying Bob.
Bob can't pay back.
But that's still pretty
useful, in some cases.
If you have some kind
of recurrent payment,
you're streaming
videos or something.
You open a channel,
you can keep paying.
One thing that's nice is
these can be really fast.
So this, you have
to actually wait
till it's in the blockchain.
But these transactions,
there's no blockchain involved.
You just sign it, and hand
it over to the other party.
And as soon as they've
received it, they're like, yep,
I got the money.
So this can be very low latency.
So this is pretty cool.
There are limitations.
So, yeah.
Bob keeps getting these
half signed transactions
with more and more
money going to him.
The old ones are useless.
Why would I keep
this old transaction
where I got one coin?
Just delete it.
So Bob only actually
has to store one thing.
Bob also has to be
very careful, though.
He's got to sign and broadcast
one of these before next week.
If he doesn't, Alice could
just broadcast the refund
transaction.
And you know, he thinks
he's getting three coins,
but Alice is like, no, I'm
just taking all 10 back.
And Bob was like, shoot,
I just got ripped off.
So from the Bitcoin
network's point of view,
no one's seen any of this.
All they see is the
fund transaction.
Nothing happens for days.
And then, they see
one of these payment
channel closing transactions.
And they might see multiple.
Right?
Bob could broadcast all three.
It would be dumb.
Bob only wants this one.
But you're, basically,
using double spends
to create these channels.
yes?
AUDIENCE: So the
refund transaction
is pretty much insurance,
right, for Alice?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
If it happens, that means either
Bob went down or Bob never--
you should never
use it in real life.
It's insurance so
that you're not
worried that Bob's just
going to run off and get
your funds stuck.
AUDIENCE: So in the case
that, both, Allison and Bob
are honest actors, I
guess, in this situation,
if a week does go by, there's
no reason for Alice to actually
use that refund
transaction, right?
There's no guarantee that she's
going to use it in a week.
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
But you can't keep
using the cha--
like, at that point, there's
so much trust involved.
If you keep trying to use the
channel after the weeks gone
by, Bob now--
like, it's the same reason you
can't make it bidirectional.
Right?
If Bob says, hey, here's
a transaction where
you get more of the money,
Alice is like, yeah,
but that's not
credible because I
know you can broadcast
and take more.
And similarly, if
Alice says, let's
just keep the channel
open, Bob's like,
no, that's not credible.
I know you can just take
all the money at any time.
So you handing me
these new signatures,
like, it's, sort
of, meaningless.
There's so much trust
involved that like,
why bother with this whole
payment channel thing, right?
So this is nice in
that you don't have
to trust the counter parties.
The worst they can
do is disappear.
I mean, yeah, they
can hurt themselves.
Right?
Bob can broadcast this
after this exists.
And Alice is like,
OK, that was dumb.
Thanks for the two coins back.
Or Bob can just disappear.
And Alice is like, hey,
I'm going to do the refund.
You're supposed to get these
three coins, but you're gone.
And the refund is my only
option, so I'm broadcasting it.
So you don't have to worry
about who is your counterparty.
And you don't have any debt.
There's no custody or
anything like that.
So that's really nice.
You can add trust,
but we already
have that with Coinbase
and Gemini-- you know,
the exchanges.
OK, so this is pretty useful.
Time limits.
Limits on back and forth.
Refund transactions have
to be built before the fund
transaction, and so
malleability hurts that.
Before segwit, this
was very risky,
slash you couldn't really do it.
The refund transaction has to
spend the fund transaction.
And without segwit,
you don't know
what that transaction
ID is going
to be before it gets confirmed.
And so you can try to
anticipate, oh, well
it might get malleated to
these five different things.
Let's do it.
But it's risky.
So with segit, it's nice.
You don't have to
worry about it.
OK, so any questions about the
simple, one direction payments?
Makes sense?
OK.
So how can you make
it even better?
What if you want to make it
bidirectional and last forever?
That would be much more useful.
Right?
But it's a tricky problem.
The refund transaction is
there, and the clock's ticking.
Also, how do you delete or
revoke these old transaction?
if you've signed over, OK,
you've got eight coins.
I've got two coins.
That's there forever.
And the blockchain doesn't know
that it's not valid anymore.
Right?
The whole point
of the blockchain
is to say, OK, this is gone.
Actually, between the
unidirectional and lightening,
I think--
how did the order go?
Like, Christian
Decker wrote a thing
about decrementing time locks.
And I don't think he published.
I think he published
after we wrote lightning.
But the idea was these
would have lock times.
It's like, you could
broadcast this on the 27th.
All three of these could
be broadcast on the 27th.
And then, the idea is Bob
wants to send money back.
And you put a lock
time on the 26th.
And the idea is like, oh,
now these all are 27th.
But now there's a Bob 2
Alice 8 over here that's
the broadcastable on the 26th.
And so the idea is, well,
Alice can get the money back.
Bob can go back to paying
Alice because it's sooner,
and Alice can raise.
So that helps a little in that
you can switch back and forth
a few times.
But each time you do it,
the time window gets sooner.
So that's, kind of, a cool idea.
But I think the lightening one
is nicer because it makes it--
OK, the goal is back and forth
between these two parties.
And it lasts forever.
And you can do as many
transactions as you want.
OK.
So how do you do that?
So there's two
timing up quotes that
have been added to Bitcoin.
And CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY is
pretty much for lightning,
in my opinion.
That's the real use case.
There's also
CHECKLOCKTIMEVERIFY.
So the idea of SEQUENCEVERIFY
is it's a relative lock time.
So it doesn't specify,
OK, this transaction
is valid on March 28th.
It says, this
transaction is valid
when the input it's
spending is a week old.
And by a week old, it's in
a week's worth of blocks.
In the actual software,
we don't usually use time.
We always use block height.
It's simpler to think
about, in a lot of ways.
But you can say, OK, well
I send to an output script.
And the output script
specifies that you can only
spend these coins after
the transaction creating
them has been 100 blocks deep.
So that's, kind of, an
interesting, useful thing.
Yeah, and confirmations.
If not, you can't spend it.
OP_CHECKLOCKTIMEVERIFY.
It's a lot absolute
lock time opcode.
So you require that
the transaction be
confirmed at high end or above.
So what we said in the refund
transaction, the refund
transaction, the transaction
field has a lock time.
Where is it?
Oh, well, in this case, yeah.
But the transaction
itself has a locktime.
But that's difference
from the opcode.
What the opcode does,
it says, OK, this output
has a locktime
because the output
script ensures that
the transaction itself
has a locktime.
So basically, you say
OP_CHECKLOCKTIMEVERIFY 500,000.
And then, it checks that the
transactions locktime field
is exactly equal to 500,000.
So it's a way to enforce
a transaction wide field
inside of an output.
It's a little weird.
But both of these become opcodes
that you can use in scripts.
And now, you can specify,
like, make an address that has
these weird timing properties.
OK.
Any questions about these two?
AUDIENCE: Can you
use both of them?
TADGE DRYJA: Yep.
You can mix them and match them.
CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY is
specific to an input.
So there's a sequence field in
each input that was completely
useless until like--
AUDIENCE: This or--
TADGE DRYJA: What?
AUDIENCE: Like, this or that.
TADGE DRYJA: Well, OK, so if
you look, there's a sequence.
And it was always just FFFFF.
You know, that's like 2
to the 32 or whatever.
2 to 32 minus 1, I think.
And it didn't do anything.
Satoshi put it in because
he thought, OK, this
will let you indicate finality
where you can increment
the sequence number.
So you say, OK,
this is sequence 1.
And then, I can replace
it with sequence 2.
And it didn't work
because you can't
have consensus on those things.
So this was a field that was,
sort of, unused in the inputs.
And what they did is
they said, OK, we'll
make that a sequence number
where if you now make this,
say--
how did it work--
you make the sequence
number 100, for example.
And then, in your
transaction, it will say, OK,
this transaction output
that you're spending,
is it 100 blocks old?
And if so, we're good.
If not, this input
spending fails.
So it's another check in
addition to the signature.
And then, you can also ensure
that, with CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY,
you can put in the opcodes.
You can put in the script.
OK, this must have
a sequence of 100.
And then, check that sequence
is equal or greater to the depth
of the transaction.
And yeah, you can mix them and
match them in the same script.
It's a little ugly
to use because it
was introduced as a soft work.
And they rename and op and op.
A no op opcode got
renamed to this.
This is, like, no op 3.
6 And so you have
to push the number
you're checking on the stack,
OP_CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY.
And then, you have to drop
the number off the stack
because this opcode doesn't
actually consume anything
off the top of the stack so
that it looks the same as a
no up to nodes that
don't know about it.
Anyway.
So you've got these two ways
to specify output timing.
OK.
Questions there?
Good.
So then, what you can do is
you can revoke based on timing.
So the idea of the script--
and this is, sort of,
in C like notation,
not the actual
opcodes for Bitcoin
because the actual opcodes
are, kind of, confusing--
the idea is, OK, you can
spend with 2 of 2 multisig,
essentially, right?
keyA and keyB, or keyC,
and wait 100 blocks.
And by wait 100 blocks, it means
that whatever you're spending
has to be confirmed
100 blocks ago or more.
So A and B together, they
can spend any time they want.
Together?
Oops.
C can spend, but must wait.
And A and B can grab
their coins first.
So this is a
revokable transaction.
So the idea is you've got some--
and we call it a commitment
transaction in the lightning
paper.
You've got some input.
The funding transaction output.
You're spending that.
You need 2 of 2 multisig.
So like, Bob's signs and
sends it over to Alice.
And then, you've got
that script where
it's, OK, it's Alice's key,
and you wait 100 blocks.
Or Alice's key and you
make a new key for Bob.
Like, the Bob revoke key.
And this has 2 coins.
This has 8 coins.
Oh.
Oops.
This should be our--
hold on.
I should change that.
That's, kind of, going
to be really confusing.
Wait.
I put the r in the wrong place.
Let me redo this.
That's a typo, but
it's super confusing.
Yeah, that is opposite.
Wait.
AliceR and Bob.
Alice and Bob are-- wait.
So I put the same thing on both.
Right?
Alice and Bob are--
this one is AliceR and Bob.
Yeah, and when you're
actually coding this stuff,
it's pretty easy to screw up.
There's a lot of like, wait,
who is Alice and who is Bob?
So in any of the code, I
don't use Alice and Bob.
I use mine and theirs.
But a lot of times,
it's not clear
because it's held by Alice.
So this is the transaction
that Bob creates, Bob's signs,
transfers to Alice, and then
it sits on Alice's hard drive.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: AliceR?
TADGE DRYJA: OK, so you
make these separate keys.
Right?
It's a key that Alice creates.
Alice creates
another pub key pair,
and tells the pub key to Bob.
And this is her revocable key.
AUDIENCE: The revocation.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
where Alice can then--
basically, what
Alice does is Alice
gives the private
key to Bob in order
to revoke this transaction.
So they're, sort
of, mirror images.
In both cases, both
parties agree, look,
Alice has got 2 coins.
Bob's got 8 coins.
Right?
But the transaction that
Bob creates and signs--
yes, the transaction that
Bob creates and signs
sends Bob 8 coins in the clear.
This is just a regular
old pay to pub key hash
where Bob gets 8 coins.
The coins that are
Alice's though, Alice
has to wait 100 blocks.
If she broadcasts this
commitment transaction,
she can't spend her
money for a day.
Like, whatever 100 block is.
Bob can get the money, but
only if he knows Alice's R key,
Alice's revocable key.
So Alice has this Bob
doesn't and in the Bob case
it's similar you know
the outputs are the same
but the ideas
Alice creates this.
Alice signs it.
Hands it over to Bob.
And in this case,
the transaction
is, well, Alice gets
2 coins in the clear.
This is immediately spendable.
No fancy scripts or anything.
Bob gets the money, but
he has to wait a day.
Or Alice can spend
the money if she
knows Bob's revokable
key is BobR key.
So either party,
at any time, can
broadcast these transactions.
The thing is, the money
they're supposed to get--
so in Bob's case, Bob can have
Bob's signature broadcast,
but now he has to wait.
No big deal.
Wait 100 blocks.
OK.
In Alice's case, OK, she can
close it and put her signature
on here, broadcast, wait
a day, spend the money.
But what's nice is
you can revoke it.
Right?
So Alice can tell Bob
I'm not going to do this.
I'm not going to use
this transaction.
You know, I deleted it.
And Bob's like, yeah,
sure you deleted it.
The way I'll prove to you
that I deleted this is I
will tell you the private key.
I'll tell you AliceR.
So now Bob knows because Bob
created this transaction.
Right?
Bob signed it.
Bob knows what it looks like.
And Bob knows, well,
yeah, this is the script.
Since Bob knows AliceR and Bob
knows his own key, Bob knows,
look, this money is mine.
This money's mine too because
I can do this immediately.
So if you broadcast
this transaction,
I don't have to even touch
this because this was my money.
And this output, I
can spend immediately
while you have to
wait 100 blocks.
And you know, my software is
going to automatically do that.
So I know AliceR's private key.
I know Bob's private key.
I just take these 2 coins.
As soon as I see
this transaction,
I take these 2 coins, I spend
them back to Bob's address
and get all 10.
So that's a pretty
convincing way for Alice
to say, look, I'm not
going to use this.
I'm deleting to show,
even if I do use it, here.
Here's the key.
Any questions about this?
AUDIENCE: Does Alice have to
voluntarily give her key up?
TADGE DRYJA: Yep.
Yeah, so Alice has
to hand it over.
Right?
This is just a regular 32 byte
private key that Alice created
and same idea for Bob.
They both create, essentially,
the same transaction
but with everything swapped.
Bob can broadcast this.
If he does, he
has to wait a day.
But if he reveals BobR
private key to Alice,
Alice knows, OK, I get
two coins in the clear.
And then, these 8
coins, I can sign this.
I can sign this.
I can get these 8
coins immediately.
Bob's got to wait a day.
So that's a way to say, look,
I'm not going to use these.
Any other questions?
OK.
So what you do with that
is, yeah, either party
can broadcast.
They have to wait.
They exchange these
revocation private keys.
And now, if they
broadcast, the counterparty
can take all the faults.
So it's pretty good.
So the idea is this is
a lightning channel.
You've got this output.
You create these dates.
OK, the first date
is Alice gets 1 coin.
Bob gets 9 coins.
Then, Bob wants to pay Alice.
So Bob says, hey, Alice,
I'm paying you 4 coins.
Here.
I'll sign and create this new
output, this new transaction.
Hand it to Alice.
And Alice says, OK, but now
we have to revoke this one.
Alice has this.
It's signed.
Alice can broadcast
it, but Alice also
wants to be sure that Bob
can't broadcast this anymore.
So they, sort of, trash it.
They reveal their R
private keys to each other.
So in practice, it
could be, well, only Bob
has to reveal the
private key, in this case
because Alice is going to
broadcast this, not this.
It's just so much simpler if
they both reveal their R keys
because then you don't have
to worry about something.
You know, what happens in
the future when Alice has 0.5
and Alice still has this thing?
So it's really simple.
They both reveal.
Now this transaction--
this state 1--
it's, basically, unbroadcast.
You know, you're
not going to use it.
And they can keep doing that.
And they can go back and forth.
Right?
So now Alice pays
Bob and says, hey.
Whoops.
I wanted to make it
go back and forth.
Oh well.
Oops.
Anyway, you can make this
like Alice back to 2 and Bob
back to 8 or whatever.
Basically, arbitrary numbers.
You can keep going
in both directions
and deleting the old one.
So that's pretty useful.
There's no lock time
for the channel itself.
The channel can just
keep going on forever.
And Alice and Bob can
keep sending these things.
It's a little more complicated.
Yeah, I didn't put the messages.
But they have to
send four messages.
You can optimize it to three.
Right.
So if you have Alice and
Bob, the first thing they do
is Alice sends a signature.
So let's say they're at state 5.
OK, so she says, here's a
signature for state six.
And Bob says, OK, I'll give
you a signature for state 6.
So now, they both
build the state 6.
All right?
Let's say, go from 5 to 6.
And then, Alice
can say, OK, I'll
give you your revocation
key for state 5.
And then, Bob can
say, OK, I'll give you
a revocation key for state 5.
And then, they're done.
They've created the new state
and revoked the old state.
Alice can not put rev 5
here in the same message.
Do you know why it went on?
AUDIENCE: You need rev key.
TADGE DRYJA: Well, yeah.
Rev key just abbreviate
to rev. So why would this
be bad if Alice says,
look, here's state six,
and I'm revoking my
claim on state 5?
What goes wrong if you do that?
AUDIENCE: Bob just
takes them all.
TADGE DRYJA: Not quite.
Bob broadcasting state
6 is OK, in that case.
AUDIENCE: Bob can sign
the rev key for 5.
TADGE DRYJA: No because
state 5 is not broadcast.
Right?
Only Alice can sign
and broadcast state 5.
So the problem with this is,
if you do this, Bob's fine.
Alice is stuck
because Alice does not
have state 6 on her drive.
All Alice has on her
drive is state 5,
and she's just revealed the
key for state 5 to revoke it.
So basically, Alice has
nothing, at this point.
And Bob can just wait,
and Alice is stuck.
And that's a really
good position for Bob
to be in because Bob is like,
hey, I can close the channel.
I can close the channel
at state 5 or state 6.
Probably, he wants state 6.
Usually, you're sending money.
But I can close this
channel, and you can't.
So give me some money, and
I'll close the channel.
That's the attack.
AUDIENCE: So
conceptually, a new state
has to be created before
you can revoke it.
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
And you want it on your side.
So this is creating
a new state for Bob,
but it's revoking the old
state for Alice if and when
you do this.
So that's dangerous.
Alice doesn't want to do that.
So the simplest way is,
OK, create the new state
by signing 6, revoking
5, revoking 5.
You can optimize this though.
Can you guys see the--
it reduces the three messages?
AUDIENCE: He can
send rev 5 back?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
He can send 6, 6 rev
5 at the same time.
So you can do it down
into three messages.
So that's cool.
It's basically, here's state 6.
OK, here is state 6, and I
revoke my claim on state 5.
OK, revoke my claim on state 5.
Then, they both update their--
once this happens,
the UI is finished.
AUDIENCE: And you're generating
keys on the fly, right?
You don't need to
pre-generate them?
TADGE DRYJA: It ends up being
faster if you pre-generate,
like, one key ahead
where you say like, hey,
here's the next public key I'm
going to use so that I can--
because Alice, when
she's building state 6,
she needs to know Bob's
revocation key in the state 6.
So you pre-share
one or two steps
ahead so that you
don't have to say, hey,
can you give me the next key?
OK.
Otherwise, you'd have
this message where it's
like request state six key.
Send it.
Send the signature back.
So there's more data in these
messages without optimizing.
AUDIENCE: So I assume with
public keys, in that case,
it's similar.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
Yeah, so you also put
some public keys in here.
And this is the private key.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Where does
state 6 [INAUDIBLE]??
TADGE DRYJA: In here.
You're sending the signature,
but you can also send
here's how much I'm giving you.
Here's what the
times and stuff are.
Most of it can be computed
because the transactions don't
change that much.
The scripts are the same.
Everyone knows what this
is going to look like,
so you don't have to
actually send too much data.
Another optimization I didn't
put in is you're going to,
potentially, have to retain
all of these R private keys.
So if you make a million
states and 900 and whatever
are revoked, Bob has
to keep track of all
those million old
Alice private keys.
And Alice has to keep track of
all those old Bob private keys.
That's, kind of, annoying.
Not the end of the world,
but it's like 32 bytes each.
Can be a couple
hundred megabytes
if you use this channel a lot.
So I thought I came up with it.
But at the same time, when I was
coming up with it, I was like,
no, I'm pretty sure this
is in some paper somewhere,
and I can't find it.
And then, talking
to people here,
apparently, it's Goldwasser.
Like, a professor here came
up with it in, like, the '80s.
I called it elkrem because
spelled backwards it's
merkle, right?
So you have a binary tree.
And you say, OK,
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
6 Is the root, for example.
And when you want to
descend to the left,
you take the value here,
append an l, or maybe 0 is left
and 1 is right or something
or l or r, and you hash it.
So you say, OK, I'm
taking this value,
sticking something on
hashing to get down here.
And similarly to here,
you make a big tree.
The idea there is you can
reveal things sequentially
and say, OK, I reveal 0.
Fine.
I'll store it.
I'll reveal 1.
Store it.
I reveal 2.
Now, you can delete 0 and 1
because you know the parent,
and you can compute 0
and 1 from knowing 2.
Right?
So I give you 0.
Give you 1.
Give me 2.
You delete 0 and 1.
Going to give me 3, 4, 5.
You delete 3 and 4.
When I give you 6,
you delete 2 and 5.
So that way, you only have
to store login secrets.
Given 0 and 1, you
can't compute 2.
And given 2, 3, and 4,
you can't compute 5 or 6.
But once you've got them, you
can compute all the old ones.
So if we do that
for the secret keys,
that reduces storage a lot.
So that's kind of a
nice optimization.
It was pretty quick.
And so then, your
total data you're
storing for these channels
never gets more than a kilobyte
or two.
So that's pretty useful.
OK.
Other questions on this?
This alone, actually,
is really complicated.
AUDIENCE: You only want
one active state, right?
TADGE DRYJA: So there is a,
sort of, superposition time here
where--
so let's say this is time 0.
This is time 1.
This is time 2.
This is time 3.
So at time 1, Bob's got 2
states he can broadcast.
Right?
Bob's like, I can do 6 or 5.
Alice can only broadcast 5.
But Alice knows that
Bob can broadcast 6.
So Alice is also like, well,
I'm not sure which it is.
From Alice's perspective,
if I close, I'm at state 5.
If Bob closes, he's at state 6.
And then, at state 2, Alice
can only broadcast state 6
but Bob can broadcast--
sorry, Alice can
broadcast either,
but Bob can only broadcast one.
So yeah, during
this process, it's
not clear which state it is.
And you know, if something
happens, like Alice sends sig--
signature for 6--
and Bob goes offline.
Then, it's like, OK, I
never got a response.
I'll just try to close
at state 5, I guess.
And then, I guess that
payment never went through.
But then, Bob could say, no,
I got it and broadcast it.
So things can get
weird where you're not
really sure what happens here.
So it's more a UI
issue where, in the UI,
you only show things
after you get to the end.
Hopefully, in most
cases, this whole process
takes a fraction of a second
because you're just sending
some messages to each other.
So that's the nice part.
That's, sort of, the
lightning-y thing.
It's fast right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does this
require both actors
to be online at the same time?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
Yeah, right.
So they're sending
messages to each other.
They can't really
pre-compute these things
because they don't
know how much money is
getting sent back and forth.
So when you're signing
state 6, you're
also signing the output values.
And when Bob receives state 6
and signs his version of state
6, he also is like,
you know, I don't know
how much money I'm getting yet.
So I need to sign off on that.
So yeah, both parties need
to be online to receive,
which is different than
normally in Bitcoin.
That's the same as the
uni-directional payment
channels.
In the unidirectional one,
where Bob's the receiver,
he doesn't have to sign.
But he still has to be online
because the transaction just
goes directly to him.
It doesn't go onto
the block chain.
None of these are
publicly known.
OK.
AUDIENCE: One question.
TADGE DRYJA: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why do we
care about old states?
Say you had a million states.
Why do we care
about the old ones?
TADGE DRYJA: Well, this was
state 1 where Alice had 1
and Bob had 9.
And then, you keep going,
and the general trend
is Bob's losing money.
Right?
You go back and forth but,
at the end, Bob has 1.
Bob needs to worry that
Alice holds onto state 1.
And then, months
later, broadcasts it
while Bob's not watching.
Sorry, wait.
No.
Opposite.
Alice has to worry
about Bob broadcasting
state 1 in the future.
AUDIENCE: Well, everything's
going to be revoked, right?
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
So you still need to
keep the secret, though.
It's revoked, but the
whole process of revocation
is Bob gives a key to Alice.
So if Bob forgets that key--
sorry.
If Alice forgets this
key, Bob can broadcast it.
And then, Alice can't grab it.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't stop
them from broadcasting.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
they can broadcast.
So from the network's
perspective,
these are all equally valid.
The network has no
idea which came when
or anything like that.
The only way you enforce it
is, if Bob broadcasts this,
Alice is like, uh uh,
I'm taking this one
because I have the key.
So that's also a pretty
significant, different security
model.
It's a security reduction.
Right?
Now, you have to actively
defend your channel
because if you go offline--
I'm Alice.
I'm supposed to have 9 coins.
I go on vacation.
I turn off my
computer, and Bob knows
I've turned off my computer.
Then, Bob can say,
oh, Alice is out like.
It's this 100 block delay.
She's not going to be online.
I'm just going to broadcast
this, get the 9 coins,
wait 100 blocks, and then
sweep them as soon as I can.
And then, Alice comes back,
plugs in, and it's like, oh,
you were-- wait.
Oh, it says I lost 8 coins.
What?
Because Bob defrauded,
so you have to be online.
I think I'm going to
get into it next time.
There is a way to
outsource that so that you
don't have to be watching.
You can have someone
else watch for you.
And I'll, probably, talk
about that next time.
But then, the last
20ish minutes--
yeah, so this is cool.
This is lightning channels.
Two parties.
Indefinite.
You still need to create
a channel to pay people.
So you're going to do
1 on chain transaction
to open the channel.
1 to close the channel.
Potentially, 2 to
close the channel,
but that's pretty rare.
If you need to immediately grab
it, then you're time sensitive,
and you're going to have
two closing transactions.
If you close normally--
like, you close
the current state--
you need to wait 100 blocks
for your money to be active.
But you don't have to spend
it immediately after that.
You can just leave
it because you know.
So in this case, let's say,
this is Bob's held transaction.
Bob broadcasts it.
Bob knows, OK, Alice
gets her 2 coins.
I get my 8 coins.
I have to wait 100 blocks,
but I don't actually
have to spend it
after 100 blocks.
I can just leave it in my
wallet because Bob knows
he never gave Alice this key.
So this clause-- this or
Alice and BobR key-- this
is not going to happen.
So Bob's safe and
just leaves it.
So he can just
use that, as well.
However, if it's the no
you don't kind of thing,
then you have to do
two transactions.
That's rare though.
So this is pretty
good, but you still
have to do two transactions.
So if you use this, you open
a channel, you use it once,
and then you close it.
Well, that was dumb.
You just paid twice as much
in fees that you needed to.
So it's useful for some
things, not for others.
Could we do something like
multiple party channels?
So there's research about this.
It gets real ugly real fast.
Like, I want a single
channel with three
or four users or, like,
a tree of channels
where the first top output has 4
of 4 multisig and then branches
into these 2 of 2 multisigs.
There's a lot of
interesting ideas,
but it gets a little ugly.
But the off chain
scalability gets bad.
There's a lot of n
squared kind of stuff.
So what about a forwarding
network of point
to point channels?
So OK, we have these
two party channels,
and people are
connected with them.
So Alice and Bob have a
channel, and Bob and Carol
have a channel.
So this would be cool.
Alice can just say hey, Bob, I
will pay you if you pay Carol.
And you can do that.
Alice says, look, I'm
just making a new state
where you have an extra coin.
Now, please, give
this extra coin Carol.
And Bob says, yeah, OK and does.
So the word there that
should have immediately
raised a, uh oh, that's not how
this stuff works, is the word
please.
You don't say please in Bitcoin.
So yeah, the other option
is Bob just keeps it.
So Alice says, OK, here.
I'll add a coin to your
output in this channel.
And please add a coin
to Carol's output
in your channel with her.
And Bob says, yeah.
No, I'm just going
to keep the coin.
Thanks.
So this might not be super
crazy in that, well, you
got a channel with them.
Maybe they're [INAUDIBLE] chain.
Also, you can you reduce
the number of coins
you send per update.
You can say, look, I'm going
to send one Satoshi at a time.
And so worst case,
you keep one Satoshi
that you shouldn't have.
Right?
You could.
It's not as scalable,
though, because let's say
you want to send a
lot of money to Carol.
You're going to have to keep
doing these little things.
It's, kind of, annoying.
Also, what if you
want multiple hops
where you're not even sure who's
in the middle of your chain?
It doesn't work for that.
OK.
So you can have
what's called HTLCs.
And these are even
more complicated.
OK, so the idea is it's
Hash/Time Locked Contract.
Or Hash/Time Lock Contract.
Whatever.
The script is,
essentially, this.
KeyA and preimageR.
You need to present
the preimage of a hash.
Or KeyB and some
absolute lock time.
Op check lock time verify.
And it's important that this
is an absolute time, not
a relative time
because these should
be able to expire, regardless
of when they get broadcast
onto the blockchain.
So the idea is, in this case--
so let's say A is
Alice, B is Bob--
Alice gets the money if
she knows this preimageR.
This 32 bite.
So what actually goes
here is the hash of R.
It's like a Pay-to-PubKey
Hash, where you say op dup,
op hash 160, the
thing, op equal verify.
So you need to know some
preimage, and you need to sign.
Or you can be Bob, and then you
can sign after a certain date.
So this is, kind of, nice.
It's like, well, if R is
known, then it's Alice's money.
If R is unknown,
then it's Bob's money
after a certain period of time.
OK, so this was the revokable
transaction where Alice
got 2 coins, Bob's got
8 coins, and then you
add a third output, this
HTLC output where now Alice
has 2 coins, Bob has 7 coins,
and Alice might be getting
an extra coin if she learns R.
Bob gets the coin back
after height 500,000.
So similarly, with this it's
like, OK, this is Bob's money.
But if he does something
bad, Alice can grab it.
This is Alice's money if she
knows R. If she doesn't, Bob
gets it back.
So there's no-- like,
really, this is Bob's money.
Right?
This only happens if someone's
trying to rip someone off.
This, on the other hand,
is well it depends.
Is Alice going to
learn R or not?
And what is R?
OK.
So the multi-party
adversarial payment model.
So the lightning forwarding
is Alice wants to pay Carol.
Right?
She doesn't want to just ask
Bob to keep forwarding the funds
because she doesn't trust Bob.
So she connects to Carol--
and by connect I mean, like,
regular TCP connection--
and says, hey, Carol,
make a random number R,
and send me the hash.
carol OK, here you go.
Carol knows H, which is the hash
and R, which is the pre-image.
She sends over H to Alice.
Alice then says to
Bob, hey, I'm going
to add an HTLC to our channel.
So basically, Bob, if you
know the pre-image of H--
if you know R--
you can get this coin.
If not, I get the
coin back after 5:00.
And then, Bob says, OK, cool.
I know H now, but I don't know
R. So I can't grab this money.
I don't know this,
so there's no way
this is going to be my money.
It's just going to go
back to you after 5:00.
And Alice says, yeah, but
Carol knows R, so ask Carol.
Bob says, OK, I get it.
I will forward this on to Carol.
And then, I create
a similar output.
I make sure that these are
the same R or the same H.
I don't know R yet.
But I say, hey,
Carol, if you know R--
if you know the pre-image of H--
you can get this coin.
If not, after 4:00 o'clock,
I get the money back.
And then, Carol says, oh, cool.
Well guess what?
I know R because I made R up.
So from Carol's
perspective, Carrol
could broadcast this onto
the blockchain immediately.
And she will be able to grab
the money because she knows
R. She has to grab it soon
because, by 4:00 o'clock,
Bob can grab the money.
And if Carol does this--
she closes the
channel, she uses R
because she knows it to take
this coin from this output.
Carol doing that will reveal
R to everyone in the world
because it's on
the blockchain now.
And so then Bob can
say, ah, I know R now.
I need to get this money.
So Bob can close the channel.
Grab the money.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Those times are
actually block heights, right?
TADGE DRYJA: In the software,
yeah, we use heights.
You could do it with time.
The main reason for
heights is, what
if a block's full because
height's, sort of, variable.
Like, maybe a bunch of
blocks come out quickly,
and maybe they come out slowly.
So time is a little
dangerous in that you
could say, OK, 4:00 o'clock.
But maybe in the
next five hours,
only a couple blocks
come out, just by chance.
And they're full, and you're
not able to broadcast.
You're not able to get
this in, and it's risky.
So the height takes into account
the variable nature of it
a little bit better.
AUDIENCE: What if there's some
situation where blocks are
[INAUDIBLE]?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
Well, child pays for parent--
yeah.
So the question is, what if
the fees get really high?
The thing is, this whole process
should take a few seconds.
So it's not like these outputs
have weird fees that are old.
One issue is what if you're
building these states
back and forth.
And then, you sit on
one for a few weeks.
And then, the fee
rate goes way up.
And you're like
shoot, if I tried
to broadcast these
transactions, the fee's too low
and it might not get confirmed.
It's not a huge risk
because if you're not
trying to rip people
off, you don't actually
have any time risk.
In this case, this gets
built. This gets built.
These are, sort
of, in real time.
And so you know what the
fee rate is in the network,
so you can adapt to it.
But yeah, that's
an interesting one.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are there any problems
in this system being slow?
Because I think, as we
were reading literature
prior to blockchain,
like 1980, that I
read some stuff about
distributed computing
that if you n
number of nodes, you
need a minimal number
of 3 [INAUDIBLE]
or something in order
to get consensus.
But does blockchain
sort of make something
underneath all of the--
TADGE DRYJA: You don't need
global consensus in that--
I did only 3, so you can't show.
If you have four,
you can sort of
say-- let's say you have
Alice, Bob, Carol, Dave.
You don't actually have
to know the whole thing.
You just have to know the
person before you and the person
after you.
And you don't care what
the actual endpoints are.
So to some extent, Bob
doesn't need to know.
Maybe Alice got this HTLC
forwarded from someone
else before.
And Bob's like, all I know is I
could get money from Alice if I
know R, and Carol
gets it from me
if she knows R. And maybe
that keeps going or something.
You don't need global consensus.
AUDIENCE: And that's
because of how it's chained?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like the message?
You're only concerned
with the channels
you're participating in.
If there's something
else happening before it,
you might want to watch
in case ours shows up.
But you don't have
to worry about it.
And then, these will
all get broadcast.
The failure mode is broadcast
everything onto the blockchain,
and let the blockchain
sort it out.
And that's very high latency
because it's, like, 10 minutes.
But the idea is the
blockchain already
has that global
consensus because it's
really high latency and
everyone can agree on it.
So I think that's
the basic idea.
Yeah, so what you could do here
is you could just close it.
Right?
You could broadcast this whole
transaction on the blockchain
and get the payment through.
That's really inefficient.
You want to keep your channels
open so what instead happens--
when everything's working.
It could happen.
right?
Carol could just broadcast it.
OK, that's annoying.
Whatever.
But no one loses money.
Or Carol can go
offline, at this point.
And then, these
things get stuck.
And there's all sorts of weird
things that can go wrong,
but you don't lose money.
But what happens
when things go right
is Carol says, hey, Bob,
I know R. And so really,
this whole crazy HTLC
thing, it's just my money.
I know what R is.
You're not getting this
money at 4:00 o'clock
because I know R. So here.
Look.
I'll tell you R. And
when Carol tells Bob R,
she's doing two things.
She's proving that
this HTLC is her money.
She's also giving Bob R so that
he can then grab Alice's money.
And so as soon as she
reveals R to Bob, Bob says,
yeah, I agree.
This HTLC is superfluous,
at this point.
I know you know R, so
this is just your money.
And if it gets close
to 4:00 o'clock,
I know you're going to broadcast
this channel onto the chain
if I don't let you clear it out.
So let's just make a new state
through these state updates
where you just have
the extra money.
Let's clear out that HTLC.
So that 1 coin goes to you.
And Carol's like, OK, cool.
I agree.
We'll sign this,
and they'll all just
get rid of the HTLC output.
Then, Bob goes to Alice and
says, hey, Alice, guess what?
I know R. So this part,
I'm going to do it.
I know R and Bob.
Alice, after 5:00 o'clock,
it's not happening.
If you stop answering
me and it gets to 4:30,
I'm just going to broadcast
the channel on chain
and grab it that way.
And then, Bob
reveals R to Alice.
Alice says, oh yeah, you do know
R. OK, we'll clear the HTLC up,
and you get the money.
And then, Alice gets
R. And that's, sort of,
a receipt for the payment.
And Alice knows, well,
Carol was the one who
told me H. Carol must
have gotten the money.
Right?
So that's my
confirmation of that.
AUDIENCE: How does creating a
new channel state of the HTLC--
how does that provoke
the HTLC itself?
TADGE DRYJA: Oh, so I
didn't put it in the script.
But it's revocable the same
way the regular outputs
are revocable.
There's also this,
which you don't even
have to do because the idea
is that the HTLCs are very
small in comparison with the
other outputs in the state
that, if you try to
broadcast an old one,
you'll lose way more
than the HTLCs worth.
But you can also tack on a or
other clause to the HTLC script
with a relative lock time.
So there's actually a couple
different ways to do it.
The simplest is
you just say, look,
I've got 2 coins, 7 coins,
and then a 1 coin HTLC.
I'm not going to risk my
7 coins to go back and try
to get this 1 coin in HTLC.
But that's not how most
of the software does it.
You just add a new clause.
OK, so this is a multiple
party adversarial.
Whoops.
So yeah, that would
be really useful.
Right?
You build lots of nodes
with channels connecting.
And they form a big graph.
And then, you can
request payment
routing via these HTLC outputs.
And if you open a few
channels, then you
can pay lots of different
users on the network.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I may
have missed this,
but what is Bob's incentive
in relaying transactions?
TADGE DRYJA: OK.
So yeah, Bob could charge a fee,
or he could just be a nice guy.
That's, basically, the--
AUDIENCE: But you said you
never ask for [INAUDIBLE],,
because you know
Bob's not a nice guy.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
so you can pay him.
It's going to be
hard to pay him much
because Alice is going to say,
look, we've got a channel.
We're using it.
If you charge me a ton to
forward payments to Carol,
I'm just going to
close the channel
and open with someone
who does it cheaper.
So yeah, you can make the
amounts slightly less.
So Alice says, I'm
sending you 1 coin.
And Bob says, OK, I'm sending
0.9999 coins to Carol,
and I'm keeping the difference.
You can have that.
And then, it's
really up to Carol
to decide if the fee-- because
all Alice knows is, hey,
I'm sending one coin.
What if Bob puts a crazy
fee, like 1/2 a coin?
Carol sees 0.5.
And Carol's like, no,
that's way too low.
I don't know what
happened, if Alice
sent 0.5 and Bob
forwarded it to me
or if Alice sent 1 and
Bob forwarded me 0.5.
But I'm not accepting this.
Right?
I'm not going to
reveal R to you.
I'm just going to say no.
So you can do that.
At this point, Carol
has not yet revealed
R. Carol can refuse
and say, look, Bob,
I'm not going to
accept this HTLC.
We can just clear it out
right away without revealing R
and just, basically,
undo what we just did.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So two
follow-ups to that.
The first is, can there
be a situation where
it's an efficient market
place for these relaying
points in the network
where Alice asks for a bid,
and the lowest
transaction fee wins
and she routes it from that?
TADGE DRYJA: You can.
So let's say Alice is connected
to three Bob's in the middle,
and then asks all
of them, hey, what
are you going to charge me
to forward a coin to Carol?
Then, they can all answer.
It's a little weird because
they can lie, at that point
because they haven't
actually signed anything.
And this, Bob can say,
oh, I'll do it for free.
And this Bob says, oh,
I'll do it for 1/2 a coin.
And this Bob says, I'll
do it a tenth of a coin.
And then, you try to
go for the free one,
and Carol gets some really
low amount and says,
I'm not telling you
R. Let's cancel this.
And then, if Alice trusts
Carol, Carol could be like,
Alice, Bob just tried to
charge a ridiculous fee.
Don't use this.
You know, this Bob is bad.
And then, you try the other
Bob, and the other Bob
does the right thing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can't Alice just
send directly to Carol?
TADGE DRYJA: Open a channel?
So yeah, you could.
You just have to open a channel.
AUDIENCE: Is that
expensive or something?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
You have to go on chain.
We, sort of, saw a preview
of it in November, December,
and January where it
was actually, kind of,
expensive to use Bitcoin.
Now it's cheap again.
Costs a few cents.
But for a month or two,
it was like, oh shoot.
Like, this costs $5 to make
a on chain transaction.
And so creating a direct
channel from Alice to Carol,
it might cost $5.
Or it might cost $20.
Or long term, if everyone's
trying to use the blockchain
and the fees go really high, it
could be, kind of, expensive.
And so the idea is, well, if
I've got a channel already,
I'd rather use that and move
my money around that way
without having to
touch the blockchain.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
it be a graph problem
trying to figure out what the
cheapest way to get to Carol
is?
Would that be [INAUDIBLE],,
and would that be scalable?
TADGE DRYJA: So
you can sort of--
so it's [INAUDIBLE] or
it's like [INAUDIBLE],,
kind of, if you know
the whole graph.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
then you have to ask.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
So the one part is if
you know the whole graph.
And you can know the whole
graph because the graph never
gets bigger than the UTXO set.
Every channel is a
transaction output.
And so, if you're
running a full node
and you have the whole
UTXO set, the entire graph
is on the order of that size.
So maybe it's twice
as big in that
you have to have some
extra metadata about what
these outputs are.
And Bob and Carol
can make proof.
So like, oh, here
is our channel,
and it's in the UTXO set.
And we can reveal our pub
keys, the big O in here.
So if you have the
whole graph, you
could do some routing that's
in login kind of speed.
But then, it might not work.
So there's actually tons of ways
things can go wrong in this.
That's the, sort of, fun
part of dealing with it.
One of the ways it can not
work is you're like, yeah,
I found a path.
The simplest is, I found
a path, and I query Bob,
and Bob is just offline.
I'm like, oh, OK.
Well, that's not an active path.
OK, what's the
second shortest path?
OK, this other Bob,
and he says, yes.
But the fee seems really high.
So OK, I found the--
So most of the
algorithms, though,
will get you the second and
third and fourth and fifth
shortest in much less
time than recomputing
the whole thing from scratch.
So you can get a bunch of pretty
good ones and try them all.
Like query and the--
AUDIENCE: By the time
you try them all,
what if the first Bob is online
and you try the first Bob?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
The thing is, in practice,
it's all real fast.
Well right now, for a small
network, it's nothing.
But even total number
of UTXOs is on the order
of, like, millions.
Right?
So if you've got a graph
with millions of edges,
that's easy for a computer.
Right?
They'll do it in
less than a second.
And then, your main thing
here is network latency
for all of these things.
For building new states, it's
the time taken for the data
to get from one
side to the other.
It's much larger than
computing the signatures,
verifying the signatures,
building the hash tree thing.
All that stuff is real
fast compared to a network.
So the same with routing.
Looking at the graph
and dissecting it
is going to be faster than
contacting all the things.
There's a bunch of other
things that can go wrong.
So for example, this
gets built, get to here,
and Carol just stops responding.
So now you've got
these two HTLCs.
They're a third output in
your channel transaction,
and Carol's just
not saying anything.
And then, Alice goes to Bob.
He's like, Bob, what's up?
Like, we're going
to clear this HTLC.
Usually, these
only take a second.
And Bob's like,
uh, yeah, hold on.
And so it's, kind of, awkward
because now we've got this HTLC
and you don't know whose
money it ends up being.
The way to mitigate
that, Rusty--
yeah, I think it works;
Rusty's the other guy
who works on this stuff--
was that he has a
timeout period--
I think 30 seconds,
a minute, whatever--
where Alice says, OK, Bob, I
made this HTLC a minute ago.
Minute's up.
You need to either
shut down this channel
right now because you're
doing something bad,
or you need to prove to me that
a channel has been shut down
with this HTLC,
this H value in it.
And then, I know where
to ascribe blame.
So if Bob's like, yeah,
I can't contact Carol.
Carol's offline.
Then, Alice says, all right.
Well, then, shut
down the channel.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that
pretty expensive
considering Carol isn't
necessarily malicious?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
so that's a downside.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it seems
a little harsh on Carol.
TADGE DRYJA: Well, the thing
is, if you don't do that--
AUDIENCE: It just seems
to me like running
a lightning node is not anywhere
near as voluntary as running
a Bitcoin node in this
world where it's, like,
being live really matters.
Responding even faster than
the timeouts really matters.
TADGE DRYJA: OK.
OK, one thing to mitigate that.
Carol responded by
signing off on the HTLC,
and then immediately
goes offline.
It's not like you accident--
AUDIENCE: This is all protocol.
She didn't truly break
the rule by doing so.
TADGE DRYJA: Well,
part of the protocol
is, if you have an HTLC
and you don't remove it
within 30 to 60 seconds,
it's like, you know,
that's a violation of
the rules, and we're
going to close their
channels because if you're
just straight up offline,
and then it's like, well, OK,
I'm not going to
use that channel.
But it's like, oh,
I accepted this,
and immediately said, OK, I'm
not talking to you anymore.
And they're like, well, now
it's stuck because the attack
vector is build a ton of HTLCs.
You could add multiple per
channel and build them all,
and they all get stuck.
And one party is just not
responding with their R values.
And then, everyone's like,
OK, if we try to close,
our transactions now
have, like, 100 outputs.
And they're huge and
have all these fees.
Also, all these HTLCs, yeah,
they might be really little,
and we have to wait.
And then, it charges a lot of
fees to recover them and stuff.
So you don't want
people to be able to,
sort of, blow up the number
of HTLCs in your channels.
So the way to do it is,
if one of them is stuck,
you need to find
someone to blame.
And yeah, it's possible.
Right?
But the thing is, you accurately
find the person to blame.
If Carol accepts the HTLC, and
then, a split second later,
unplugs their computer,
Bob's like, what?
OK, fine.
I'm closing the channel.
You just did something
really annoying.
And Bob's like, if I
don't close this channel,
Alice is going to close the
channel on me because Alice
is going to think I'm
the one acting weird.
So yeah, there's all
sorts of weird edge cases.
There's all sorts of weird
stuff that can happen.
It's definitely more complicated
than just the straight up UTXOs
in Bitcoin.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Couldn't
Carol respond to Bob,
and then Bob be malicious
and close the channel?
And then say, hey,
Alice, check it out.
Carol was malicious.
TADGE DRYJA: Yep.
That's OK.
AUDIENCE: And then, you
wouldn't get the blame,
but Carol presumably--
TADGE DRYJA: Bob blames Carol.
Carol says, no, it
was actually Bob.
From Alice's point of
view, like, whatever.
Like, something got closed.
There was a cost to
adding this HTLC.
You know, there was a
cost to having me stuck
with this HTLC for five hours.
Right?
Something unchained happened.
So the thing is, having one
HTLC stuck for a few hours
is no big deal.
After 5:00, Alice
just goes to Bob
and is like, look,
well let's clear it.
Right?
You don't know R. If you knew
R, you would've told me by now,
so let's just get
rid of this thing.
And Bob's like, yeah, fine.
And they clear it out.
So the idea is it's
not a big attack
if you only have one of them.
You want some cost
to performing that.
And so if Bob
closes the channel--
whether it's Carol's
fault or Bob's fault--
Alice is sort of like, look,
well something happened,
so someone's bearing
the cost for this.
So they're not going
to keep doing it.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So in reality, is
it maybe like five hours,
or is it more like
couple minutes?
TADGE DRYJA: You actually
need hours because--
oh, other attack.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TADGE DRYJA: Let's say
these were both at 5:00.
Right?
And then, Carol closes
the channel right at 5:00.
Right before 5:00 o'clock, Carol
closes the channel, uses R,
grabs it.
Bob then says, oh shoot, there's
R. Alice is like, nuh uh.
Alice closes the channel right
after 5:00 and grabs hers
by signing with her key.
And then, Bob's screwed.
Right?
Bob's like, shoot.
Wait.
Carol just got the
money from me using R.
And then, Alice closed
and got the money
from me using the time out.
And I didn't get anything.
I lost the money on this side,
and I didn't get the money
on this side.
So Bob just had a
huge loss there.
So Bob really wants to make
sure that this is later.
Like, Alice can't get
the money until well
after Carol can get the money
with the timeout function.
Or sorry, well after Bob can
get his money with the timeout.
AUDIENCE: Did Bob
set that time though?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
Hold on.
Bob sets this time, yes.
Then, Alice sets this time.
AUDIENCE: So he just has to
make sure they're [INAUDIBLE]..
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, he has
to make sure his earlier.
And continuing that, if
Carol makes HTLC today--
if she makes it at 3:00
o'clock or whatever--
I don't remember
what the defaults are
in the different-- like,
I do it all in testnet.
And so in testnet, I do five
blocks because who cares.
I think in the main net
one's people are trying out,
they do quite a bit
more because it's better
to have your money stuck for a
day than to lose it, I guess.
So you can make different
time outs and stuff like that.
OK, what else?
I'm, basically, done.
There's a whole bunch of
other cool things you can do.
And I think I'll talk
about that next time.
Yeah, you can do
cross chain swaps.
So this is a preview of after--
just real quick.
This channel and
this channel do not
need to be on the
same blockchain.
Totally fine for this to be
Bitcoin and this to be Litecoin
or this to be Dogecoin.
It actually totally works.
So that's kind of cool.
Security.
So you want to monitor your
channels in case someone
tries to rip you off.
You can outsource that
in a nice way where
you can give it to a
third party and say, hey,
I've got this channel.
Watch it for me.
Not only that.
I've got a channel.
Watch it for me.
I'm not going to
tell you what channel
it is, how much money I have.
Basically, anything.
And you can still
protect it for me.
So that's, kind of, cool.
You can anonymously do that.
Stuck HTLCs, I
just talked about.
Dust and fees gets really ugly.
There's a lot of cool
stuff you can do.
So I think the
schedule is I'll talk
about the rest of lightning
on Monday after spring break,
and then go into discrete
log contracts, which
is another similar construction
on the Wednesday after.
OK.
Any questions about
all this stuff?
I'm sure, yeah.
AUDIENCE: What are the
time factors that miners
pose to this situation?
TADGE DRYJA: Miners can
make time outs not happen.
If they're coordinated,
they can say
we're just going to not accept
this transaction till later.
So that's bad.
You know, there's other
weird attack factors.
The one that I
worry about most--
not most-- the one
that I worry about
is, if you make a backup of
your wallet and you restore it,
you lose all your money.
So you make a backup here at
state two onto your USB stick,
and you go home, and you
drop your laptop in the pool.
And you're like, shoot.
Well, good thing
I got my backup.
Well, sorry.
You make a backup here at
work on your USB stick.
And then, you keep
spending money.
And then, you drop your
laptop in the pool.
And then, you restore from
your USB stick to here.
And then, you try
to broadcast this.
But you've already
revealed your private keys.
And so Bob's just like, what?
Like, that's red.
Like, you revealed it.
And then, he takes
all the money.
So yeah, don't make backups.
The reason I worry about it
is it's very counterintuitive.
There's nothing in the
software that does this.
The software I can write, like,
you know, don't make backups.
Always only keep this, but
you can just copy the files.
And it seems like the
kind of thing people
might do and put warnings
on the read me's and stuff.
So that's, kind of, a big risk.
So there's a lot of how
do we make this safe.
And a lot of people
criticize it.
Like, this is too complicated.
There's enormous
communities on the internet
that hate this and hate me.
And go to RBTC sometimes.
They really don't like
the Lightning Network.
On the other hand, it's like,
well, you don't like it,
you don't have to use it.
Right?
I'm just running the software
for free for you guys
but anyway.
But yeah, and you know,
there's legitimate,
like, this is kind
of complicated.
It's not going to
work for everything.
There's all sorts of
limits to this too.